[Music]
when you think of chicken farms you
might picture chickens crammed into
small tight
cages according to the food and
agriculture organization in 2023 there
were about 34.4 billion chickens raised
globally the majority of these chickens
are pushed to lay up to 300 eggs per
year under harsh conditions a world
where chickens roam free living in
harmony with nature might sound like a
far-fetched dream but this is actually
happening in some parts of China in the
mountainous regions of guong Province a
special method of raising chickens has
existed for many years
[Music]
among the freerange chicken breeds
thriving in yanan the yanan chicken is
renowned as one of the eight best
chicken breeds in Southeast Asia these
chickens are muscular and easily
recognized by their distinctive golden
feathers thanks to their organic corn
diet they mature after 4 to 5 months of
roaming the hills and typically weigh
around 2.5 to 3
Kg besides Yang Shan chickens other
breeds living at altitudes between 800
1,500 m above sea level are also raised
in these Highland
[Music]
regions the Stark difference between
raising freerange chickens and caged
chickens lies in their living conditions
freerange chickens spend their lives
wandering the hills basking in the Sun
and foraging for food leading a natural
life that boosts both their physical and
mental health however they don't lay as
many eggs producing only around 100 to
120 eggs per year and the eggs are
smaller weighing about 40 to 45 G each
but these eggs are more flavorful and
packed with omega-3 fatty acids vitamins
and minerals the chicken's active
lifestyle also results in better tasting
meat which turns a bright golden color
when cooked
[Music]
the Journey of raising Mountain chickens
begins with high quality eggs from
reputable hatcheries or
Farms the ideal temperature for
incubating eggs is around 99. 5° f with
humidity levels between 55% and
70% it takes about 21 days for the eggs
to hatch in large scale hatching
operations like those in minching County
halong Jang Province China up to 400,000
chicks are hatched each year a
significant increase from just 70,000
chicks 5 years
[Music]
ago once hatched the chicks are usually
transferred to well ventilated coups
Farmers prepare the CPS with 7 to 10 cm
of sterilized straw or husks for insul
and warmth a coupe of around 3 S M can
hold about 100 chicks during their first
2 to 3 weeks since chicks can't regulate
their body temperature effectively
constant lighting keeps them warm enough
to eat and drink Farmers provide them
with clean warm water mixed with
electrolytes and 6 to eight small meals
a day the chicks are still fragile so
farmers keep everything clean washing
the feeding troughs twice daily and
giving them medicine as prescribed by a
vet
[Music]
as the chicks grow organic food sources
such as greens and grass are introduced
so they can get accustomed to Mountain
foraging on favorable weather days the
chickens are released to the hills early
in the morning morning and spend most of
their day there Farmers often Monitor
and live stream their chickens to build
an online customer base and boost sales
the hills where the chickens roam are
scattered with trees providing shade and
opportunities for the chickens to perch
play and catch insects the chicken's
diet is as buried as their environment
and during the summer Farmers hardly
need to feed them since grasshoppers are
abundant some Farmers even get creative
by encouraging the chickens to run more
by feeding them behind a moving
[Music]
vehicle studies from our world and data
have shown that freerange chickens
experience 57% to 70% less pain and
suffering compared to cage
chickens recognizing the benefits of
Freer range f farming the European Union
plans to ban the use of any type of
cages by
2027 to encourage egg laying Farmers
create simple nests from bamboo wood or
leaves in the mountainous regions of
tanan in northern China more than 50,000
freerange chickens roam across 200
hectares of Hills laying eggs in around
30 chicken CPS built right on the
mountain tops the CPS and sleeping areas
are often designed to save space and
mimic the mountain Terrain
[Music]
the most chickens prefer to lay eggs and
nests some might choose to lay under a
tree or directly on the ground to ensure
no eggs are missed check the grps and
roaming areas twice daily to collect the
eggs Farmers with around 7,000 chiens
can Harvest up to 9,400 eggs per day
despite the large quantities manual
labor remains High provide employment to
local World
communities after collection the eggs go
through a simple inspection and gring
process to protect the natural prot
coating on your shelves receiving only a
light cleaning workers carefully place
the eggs into paper of plastic trays to
ensure they are well protected during
transport these trays are then loaded
onto trucks and delivered to local
markets or preordered customers
[Music]
[Applause]
large scale freerange egg producers
often have on-site packing facilities
capable of packing up to 74,000 eggs
from all nearby
Farms these fresh highquality eggs are
then distributed to supermarkets and
retail stores where consumers are
willing to pay a premium offer from $3
to $4 per de in comparison P eggs May
cost only
$125 to $2 per dozen
during unfavorable we such as extreme
heat or Cal the chickens are brought
indoors to ensure their comfort and
health inside large groups still provide
enough space for them to stress their
legs perch on platforms and interact
with each other a typical prange chicken
and comfortably C about 600
chickens some Farmers prepare fresh
daily combining lovely B ingredients
from the hills with these pets and of
course regular fresh water for these
chicken
[Music]
the location of freerange farms is
carefully selected to minimize the risk
of
predation however in some cases natural
Predators such as Hawks and foxes can
pose a threat to protect their chickens
Farmers remove bushes and potential
hiding spots for Predators around the
coups they also build sturdy fences and
regularly check the surrounding areas
for signs of Predator activity if
predators are caught they are either
sold or
consumed the exact weight of chickens at
Harvest varies by breed but Freer range
chickens typically weigh between 1.8 and
2.4 kg although lighter than caged
chickens free-range chickens have more
muscle and less fat
thank you for reading our newsletter if
you enjoyed this Edition don't forget to
hit the like button and subscribe for
more updates see you in our next program
goodbye
[Music]